okay instead of a voicemail today I want
to address a bunch of emails that we
received this is it's a really horrible
situation but it's also there's a funny
element to it
so last week we use a MailChimp to send
emails like our newsletter we
communicate we use MailChimp which is a
common very well known service that's
that's out there last week
we were the target of a concerted effort
to a sort of mass report the David
Pakman show as spamming people and this
was done I'm not even gonna say exactly
how it was done but there were people
who clearly know in the same way that
they know how to constantly report us on
YouTube to try to create problems with
our YouTube account or to do reporting
on other social media platforms they
know how to report us for spamming
people who are on our newsletter
disingenuous trolling is disingenuous
trolling unfortunately this led to the
total and complete shutdown of our
MailChimp account and we were
immediately unable to send our daily
what's on the show newsletter to people
and that's horrible and we finally
gotten it fixed as of yesterday but what
was really just disappointing to me was
that I started getting dozens of emails
from people saying David is the show
over or are you are you off the show has
the show ended because I'm not getting
my daily email from you and this is
concerning this is concerning because if
I were a recipient of the email
newsletter the first thing I would do is
just go to david pakman.com and see if
there's a new show right and you would
immediately see that that there was a
new show or I would go to YouTube and I
would see that there are video clips
being published so I was a little bit I
want to pick my words carefully
surprised and distraught at the fact
that dozens of people at least thought
that the show might have ended on with
no notice whatsoever from one day to the
next on the basis of the newsletter not
going out yeah I mean I think it's
totally reasonable to write in and ask
why the newsletter isn't getting sent
out okay but it's a bit of a jump to
assume that the show was canceled or
came to a finality here's like you know
people know me well enough to know that
I will promote things of almost no
importance whatsoever for month
right I will create a multi-month
build-up for events that are of almost
no significance whatsoever don't you
know that if the show was really going
to just be ending and going off the air
it wouldn't just be like hey okay that's
it for the bonus show and then that's
there's just never another show like
please don't don't believe that that's
something I would do so the show is here
the email newsletter is back today the
bonus show today will be great we'll
talk about a judge saying that yes the
30 year-old son of a couple must move
out of their house we're going to talk
about ways to get smokers to quit we'll
talk about night time tablet and phone
usage and many many other important
things get the bonus show by signing up
at join pakman.com or becoming a patron
at patreon.com slash david pakman show